this week an odd tweet appeared in my
mention from a verified Twitter user
users prominent enough to be granted a
blue checkmark by Twitter itself this
one came courtesy of a rapper named
Talib Kweli Green I'll admit I never
heard of green until he suddenly
appeared in my mentions calling me a
racist ass it turns out Green is a
rapper with well over 1 million Twitter
followers in a long history of
quote-unquote social activism a quick
search of Greene's Twitter feed showed a
wide variety of instances of the rapper
calling people white boy and really
which is horrible he says that this does
not make him racist of course only the
term black boy would be racist
since green maintains that white people
cannot truly be victimized by racism
when I pointed out that seeming
incongruity green replied what's the
problem white boy you think white boy is
racist
wow you're dumber than I thought he then
dared me to call him black boy which of
course I would never do since that would
be racist what's greens actual argument
it seems to be that since the derogatory
slur black boy was thrown around by
lynch mobs any other derogatory slur can
no longer be derogatory this is the
rhetorical equivalent of the argument
your mom used to make back in grade
school you're not really hungry
there are children in China who are
starving to death the argument fails for
the same reason yes it turns out there
are gradations of racism just as there
are gradations of hunger but you are
hungry when you're a kid even if your
bowels weren't distended and you're a
racist if you call someone white boy in
derogatory fashion even if you're not
attempting to lynch him thanks to the
theory of intersectionality however such
logic goes by the wayside
intersectionality theory has now taken
over the college campuses leaving the
broken corpses of decency and reason in
its wake intersectionality classifies
social categories of race class gender
and sexual orientation into a hierarchy
of victimhood that decides how you
should be treated if you're a black
lesbian for example you outrank about
ranked black straight men and your view
must be treated with more caring weight
than that of the black straight man more
importantly since society somehow
classifies you as lesser than the black
straight man you are incapable of ever
doing anything to victimize that black
straight man social powerlessness means
that your individual victim status never
changes
that's why green and others on the Left
believe it's fine to use white boys slur
black people have historically seen
discrimination in America why do not
whites benefit from a more powerful
status in society at large and therefore
black people cannot possibly be racist
against white people as Morehouse
College professor dr. mark Lamont Hill
said last year
black people don't have the
institutional power to be racist or to
deploy racism
there's only one problem with this
notion it's racist racism bolstered by
power is obviously more dangerous than
racism without it but racism can be used
to achieve power - generally through the
polarization of racial groups against
one another tribalism is a powerful
force resorting to a victimhood
mentality to explain tribalism away
doesn't make it any less toxic the
faster Americans learn that the faster
racism can actually be curbed rather
than exacerbated I'm Ben Shapiro this is
a Ben Shapiro show so if I seem a little
frazzled today it's because the news is
utterly insane it's totally crazy we'll
break it down for you we will provide
you all the evidence and you will make
your own decision today yes we're going
to play a choose-your-own-adventure
version of the ben shapiro show today in
which i presents you all of the evidence
for the various theories as to why the
President of the United States just
fired the FBI director and you will be
able to choose which one you think is
the most plausible they're basically
three theories I will present my own as
well one of the three is mine and we'll
talk about which one is the most
plausible but first I want to say thank
you to our friends over at helix sleep
so if you're like me and you don't get a
lot of sleep generally if you're like me
and the news took you late into the
night then you value your sleep that
much more that's why you need a mattress
from helix sleep comm slash Ben right
now if you go to helix sleep calm slash
Ben you answer a few simple questions
they're on a 3d biomechanical model of
your body through their proprietary
algorithms and then they send you the
most comfortable mattress you have ever
slept on they have mattresses that can
differentiate two sides of the bed is so
you and your spouse don't actually have
to have the exact same type of mattress
you can choose a mattress that breathes
more you can choose a mattress that
absorbs heat more you can choose one
that's firmer or one that is softer the
mattress arrives in your mailbox in
about a week and shipping is 100% free
you open up the box it inflates right in
front of you because to foam mattress
this mattress is so good that it took
more expensive mattress and put it in
the other room because I love my helix
sleep mattress that much right now if
you go to helix sleep comm slash bending
at $50 off your first order $50 off your
order when you use helix sleep comm
slash Ben and it's no risk because you
have a hundred nights to try it out and
if you don't like it they'll pick it up
for free and give you a 100% refund
without any questions asked again that's
helix sleep comm slash Ben I sleep
better on this mattress helix sleep comm
slash bed okay so James Comey is gone
out on a raw level good news James Comey
was a crappy FBI director if you recall
last week while a lot of the right was
saying the James coming has done a
wonderful job explaining his conduct
before Congress I was saying you should
be fired I thought that he's done a
crappy job ever since July and my
opinion of him did not change from July
to now he always should have been fired
his firing is a good thing for the FBI
so on that note I'm glad that President
Trump fired him how he fired him is a
little bit weird so what we heard is
that James Comey was giving a lecture at
some FBI branch out here in Los Angeles
and in the middle of the speech the TV's
behind James Comey started showing the
news that he had been fired Ed Koch it
is a solid comedy this is the comedy
this wedding sorry it's so freakin funny
and then Comey apparently said to people
that's funded pretty funny joke and then
like five seconds later he's pulled off
stage and brought into a back room where
a letter from Trump to him is read aloud
to him by somebody and a manila envelope
is delivered by Trump's personal
bodyguard to James Comey the director of
the FBI at which point the cameras start
following James commis car through Los
Angeles it's the 405 and all of a sudden
it's back in OJ days like white Bronco
days he's being fun there's a rockets
game on TV he's being fought over the
course of Los Angeles by a camera and
Zoey ters Zoey's her mobster was the
cameraman in the OJ chase his daughter
Katie sir is now covering it the
Clintons are back Trump is back we're
living in 1994 again gang it's totally
wild so pretty amazing stuff and then
just to make things even crazier this
morning after Trump fires Comey and the
theory from the left is the reason they
fired Comey is to cover up his evil
Trump Russia collusion which as I said
yesterday there's no evidence of to this
point the theory from the left is that's
happening so who did Trump meet with
today today that after he fired combing
he met with Sergey Lavrov the Foreign
Minister of Russia and certainly kiss
react
who's that Russian ambassador who was so
controversial that Mike Flynn was
basically fired for getting on the phone
with him Trump met and took pictures of
both of them today and then the press
pool was told come in and take pictures
of them they walk in and who's sitting
there Henry Kissinger
Richard Nixon Secretary of State so I
mean this is troll master 101 it's
pretty spectacular stuff except I don't
we think I don't actually think that
Trump meant to do any of this stuff so
there are basically three theories as to
why all of this is going down the way
that it's going down but first I want to
give you the background as to what the
Trump administration says was happening
in all of this so yesterday very late
yesterday there's a letter that is
released from the White House by Rod
Rosenstein rod Rosenstein is the Deputy
Attorney General
remember Attorney General sessions has
recused himself from the Trump Russia
investigation and any investigation into
the election and so his Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosenstein he's the one who
actually writes this letter and he
wrecked his long letter explaining why
Comey has to go and he says the current
FBI director is an articulate and
persuasive speaker about leadership and
the immutable principles of the
Department of Justice he deserves our
appreciation for his public service as
you and I have discussed however I
cannot defend the directors handling of
the conclusion of the investigation of
secretary Clinton's emails and I do not
understand his refusal to accept the
nearly Universal judgment that he was
mistaken almost everyone agrees the
director made serious mistakes it is one
of the few issues that unites people of
diverse perspectives and then the rest
of the letter explains exactly what I
explained last week which is that James
Comey never should have done what he did
in July 2016 when he basically read why
Hillary was guilty then changed the law
and recommended that she not be
prosecuted and then in October he sent a
letter that again exposed Hillary
Clinton to all sorts of public scrutiny
without a tremendous amount of evidence
saying that Hillary Clinton's emails had
been discovered on Anthony Weiner's
computer and then a few days later he
exonerated her and rod Rosenstein says
all of this means that this is a mess
and Comey basically had to go now he
never explicitly said in his letter that
Comey is supposed to go which is sort of
important for reason I'll explain in a
second but he says we should reject the
departure from tradition although the
president has the power to remove an FBI
director the decision should not be
taken lightly I agree with the nearly
unanimous opinions of former Department
officials the way the director handled
the conclusion of the email
investigation was wrong as a result the
FBI is unlikely to regain public and
congressional trust until it has a new
director okay so that is the reason that
is being put forth by the Trump
administration is that Trump was really
mad at how at how James Comey handled
the Hillary investigation no yes right
Austin right what that is exactly the
right question that is exactly the right
question because here is Donald Trump
talking and not
over about how much he loves James Comey
for how he handled a Hillary
investigation and it took guts for
director Comey to make the move that he
made in light of the kind of opposition
he had with it trying to protect her
from criminal prosecution you know that
how I guess the story is that he's
really pissed and how they hurt Hillary
it was they were so mean to him
I remembered an entire campaign of Trump
chanting lock her up so no on this not
justnot okay that's a bunch of crap
that's a and here's the proof it's a
bunch of crap the director from Trump to
Comey actually firing him says quote
well I greatly appreciate you informing
me on three separate occasions that I am
NOT under investigation I nevertheless
concur with the judgments of the
Department of Justice that you are not
effectively able to lead the bureau okay
so what he's really saying there is that
he's pissed economy because he thinks
Comey hasn't closed up the Trump Russia
investigation in expedient fashion so I
want to talk about what exactly that
means because there's two theories of
how that comes down but first I need to
point out the hypocrisy of the Democrats
I've pointed out Trump's apocrypha
saying that this is all the that he had
to go because of how the Clinton
investigation was handled even though he
sort of was a fan of how the Clinton
investigation was handled in the end
because it made him win in part at least
partially okay here's the democratic
hypocrisy but let me finish with the
Republican hypocrisy first Jeff Sessions
also said that Comey had to go on the
basis of his handling of the Clinton
investigation here is Jeff Sessions way
back Wednesday and Comey did the right
thing
there's some serious allegations here
that the American people need to know
are fully investigated and I you know
FBI director Comey did the right thing
when he found new evidence he had no
choice but to report to the american
congress where he had under oath
testified the investigation was over he
had to correct that and say this
investigation is ongoing now and I'm
sure
looking what okay so this note sessions
in Trump now say that Comey has to go
because the Clinton stuff that's not
what's happening
meanwhile the Democrats are also
hypocrites so Donald Trump is ripping
Chuck Schumer because Chuck Schumer was
out there saying that this is the end of
the world and he should never fired
economy back in November he was saying
the Comey should have been fired and
Trump rightly says crying Chuck Schumer
stated recently I love that the
nicknames
you know the Trump's on his game when
the nicknames are back and dropping the
g's cryin Chuck Shumer stated recently I
do not have confidence in him James come
in any longer then act so indignant
hashtag drain the swamp so now he's
saying that he's draining the swamp of
Comey the guy who he realized in five
seconds ago and basically blew him a
kiss actually physically blew him a kiss
while he was saying that he was going to
reappoint him which is just amazing
meanwhile the Democrats are indeed
hypocrites so Nancy Pelosi saying that
this is just the worst thing in the
world that Trump fired call me I seem to
remember Nancy Pelosi saying something
different here's what Nancy Pelosi said
just a few months ago and these jobs if
you're not in it for a while you can't
take the heat and I think he just
couldn't take the heat from a Republican
so Comey should have gone back in
November but now she's all pissed at
home he's leaving I think there's an
entire montage for Democrats saying the
same thing President Trump called me and
informed me he was firing director Comey
I told the president mr. president with
all due respect you were making a big
mistake Senator Harry from Nevada v
Comey broke the law one Democratic
lawmaker is calling on Comey to resign
the FBI director okay you violated these
two protocols that kind of an ambiguity
bomb this close to election was a
terrible absent judgment I agree with
Eric Holder I think here director Comey
made a great mistake I call it an
October betrayal of long-standing FBI
protocol fitting FBI director has abused
his power is acting in concert of
coordination with the House Republicans
in this story I think that call me acted
in an outrageous way Cheney step down I
think you should take a hard look at
what he has done and it's all Democrats
from back in November that is Bernie
Sanders that is I think that's Elijah
Cummings that's a bunch of other
senators Chuck Schumer that is that was
Tim Kaine from Virginia so basically all
the Democrats back in November wanted
him fired now they don't want him fired
Jeffrey Toobin of CNN who's legal
analyst last night who's going crazy
over Comey being fired
here's a small montage of Jeffrey Toobin
the legal analyst at CNN what he had to
say about James Comey up until the point
James Comey was fired the idea that they
were obliged to do
on top of commis statement about hillary
clinton last week
it just shows at least that they are
oblivious and incompetent if not
actively partisan in this in this
presidential race Jeff first of all I'm
this whole Mark Ridge document done from
the FBI is it just a coincidence that it
happened now well perhaps it is
certainly far as someone who has made
FOIA requests to the FBI they are
notoriously terrible about responding to
them they take years they don't release
documents in any sort of orderly or
consistent way it is conceivable that
this was just a coincidence but coming
on top of the director Comey's you know
very unusual and controversial release
last week it just makes the FBI look
like a like a wing of the Republican
Party
why did James Comey compell feel
compelled to release the information
that they were looking into these emails
right before the election that may
immense legal analyst Jeffrey Toobin
spending the entire election cycle
saying Comey should be fired and then of
course he turns around and says no way
he shouldn't be fired this is all crazy
okay so this brings us to our three
theories which I will get to in just a
second our three theories of why Trump
did what Trump just did with James Comey
and this is the important part so we'll
get to that in just a second but first I
want to say thank you to our new
advertisers over at indigene oh so endo
Chino is a suit company they basically
make made-to-measure suits fit and they
fit fantastic okay I went over to an
indogene Oh store over on on Santa
Monica Boulevard in Beverly Hills and it
was a wonderful experience they fit it
directly to you they fit a suit directly
to you you pick your fabric they have
about a thousand different variations on
how you can actually have the suit done
from lapel size to the to the the weave
of the fabric to the the design of the
design of the lining of the fabric to
how the lapel button should be I mean
it's really amazing stuff super detailed
and they make sure that everything fits
directly to you over at ENSO Chino you
can visit their showroom or shop online
at endo Chino dot-com you can take your
fabric choose customizations from
Apelles to pleats the jacket linings
submit your measurements yourself you
can either do it online yourself have
your spouse do it
you already can head over to one of
their shops where they have their
professionals doing it I worked with a
gal over there who is just terrific
really knew what she was doing and was
able to advise me because I don't know
what the hell I'm talking about when it
comes to suits and what would fit the
best at Enzo Chino calm ing ou CH Ino
calm any premium Indo Chino suit right
now if you use promo code Shapiro is
just three hundred seventy nine dollars
and that's not an off-the-rack suit gang
that's it that's a that's a suit that is
made to fit you it is it will fit you
perfectly that's what they that's what
they essentially make sure happens again
it's promo code Shapiro ENSO chinos calm
any premium Indo Chino suit for just
three hundred and seventy nine dollars
which is a fantastic deal it's 50% off
their regular price for made-to-measure
premium suits I mean that is a great
deal shipping as well as free again that
is Indo Chino compro moco Shapiro you're
only going to need to buy one of these
suits and it's going to replace
everything else in your wardrobe
basically all the other since you were
not going to look crappy next to the
Indo Chino suit that you just bought
because it's made to fit just for you
there's nothing better than a tailored
suit endowed sheknows.com promo code
Shapiro that's a really great price me
when I spent for my wedding suit it was
like $1,000 way back when the most I'd
ever spent on a piece of clothing still
is the most I've ever spent on a piece
of clothing you can get you know that
same suit but better from Indo Chino at
Indo Chino calm promo codes appear for
379 bucks when you use that promo code
fantastic company it was a lot of fun to
visit the shop by the way you should go
over and if you can you should go over
and check it out in person if not send
in two measurements and they will send
you a suit that is made to order okay so
here are the three theories about why
Trump fired James Comey now so they're
really two questions one is does it have
anything to do with the Trump Russia
investigation and the second is why did
you do it now so as we pointed out it
makes no sense to suggest that Donald
Trump fired James Comey over his
incompetence over the Hillary Clinton
investigation but that is very number
one so theory number one is that he
fired him friend competence multiple
letters from the administration say that
Trump was told over and over and over
the Comey needed to go there are a
variety of reasons why he needed to go
number one
his July 2016 exoneration of Hillary
Clinton number two the October 28th
letter informing Congress that the FBI
hadn't covered new emails and number
three that just a couple of days ago he
appeared before Congress to explain
himself made an ass of himself and the
FBI had to restate the evidence in order
to prevent him from
having committed perjury he lost the
trust of the administration and so he
had to be fired that's the most clear
and obvious explanation it also does not
explain the timing it doesn't explain
why exactly this happened when it
happened it doesn't explain why exactly
Trump did it now right he should have
fired Comey immediately upon entering
office or beforehand you should have or
if you wanted to fight him now it should
have gone them to listen director Comey
we've lost confidence in you but we want
to make sure that there's some sort of
institutional stability there's not a
big scandal we want to have your help in
transitioning away from this being your
department in somebody else's department
here's a list of nominees let's work on
this and let's try and figure out a way
to transition this more smoothly that's
not what happened and there are serious
questions as to why that didn't happen
there's a lot of evidence to suggest
that this had nothing to do with the
Clinton investigation number one as I
mentioned Trump is obviously very very
angry at James Comey over Russia in that
letter as I mentioned there's a phrase
that says well I greatly appreciate you
informing me on three separate occasions
I am NOT under investigation I
nevertheless concur with the judgment of
the DOJ are not able to effectively lead
the bureau so he's really pissed at
Comey over Russia and explained this
doesn't necessarily mean corruption but
he's pista Comey over Russia Politico
has reported something similar today he
had grown and raised by the Russia
investigations to advisors said
frustrated by his inability to control
the mushrooming narrative around Russia
he repeatedly asked aides why the
Russian investigation wouldn't disappear
demanded they speak out for him he would
sometimes scream at TV clips about the
probe one adviser said Trump had grown
angry with the Russia investigation
particularly Comey admitting in front of
the Senate that the FBI was
investigating his campaign so he's
pissed at Comey for not coming out and
saying there's nothing here and so he
fired him is the theory he's been using
Twitter to bash the Trump Russia
investigation the day before he fired
economy he tweeted the Russia Trump
collusion story is a total hoax when
will this taxpayer-funded charade end
the next snake home he was gone Third
Point Rosenstein remember the guy who
wrote that long letter explaining why
Comey should go his letter was dated
yesterday if this was a long time in
coming
why was the letter about when he should
be fired dated the day that he was fired
so here's the problem
okay the Trump administration said that
it took them 18 days to fire Michael
Flynn after they were informed by the
acting Attorney General the Michael
Flynn was compromised by the Russians
but it took them apparently 18 seconds
to fire the FBI director after the
Deputy Attorney General said oh by the
way he's batted in
job so that's this was basically just an
excuse
clearly Trump surrogates don't know
what's flying so this makes it look like
it was spur-of-the-moment not like this
is a long time in coming and he clearly
didn't fire call me over to the Clinton
stuff as we pointed out earlier so
theory number one has some holes in it
this theory that Trump fired him for
simple incompetence now that's you know
there are people who are who are trying
to maintain that so there was a there's
a yesterday that this was coming Sean
Spicer was asked at a press conference
whether Comey had Trump's confident and
he said this does the president still
have confidence full confidence with the
I director James Comey I have no reason
to believe I hadn't asked him so I I
don't I've not asked the president since
the last time we talked to spoke about
this and last time you saw that he said
he did have confidence but you're not
sure to say that again now I I don't in
light of what you're telling me I don't
want to start speaking on behalf of the
president without speaking to him first
so that was a hint that this was coming
spicer disassociating himself Susan
Collins senator from Maine she says that
commis refusal to indict Hillary is the
reason why he's gone it seems to me that
this may have been the inevitable
conclusion of director Comey's decisions
last July to go public with the reasons
that he had decided not to recommend an
indictment of Hillary Clinton I think
that he is a very well-intentioned
individual but bad decision to bypass
the normal rules of the Justice
Department which he could have granted
the Deputy Attorney General she's
backing the narrative from the
administration but the problem is I've
pointed out here is that there's real
timing problems Charles Krauthammer said
the same thing last night
fire him summarily with no warning in
the middle of May because as I'm going
to happen in July is almost going
explicable second the reason ostensibly
is as you read in that letter for doing
something that you're not supposed to do
to use herb the Attorney General but
second to release all that information
which was damaging to Hillary Clinton
Donald Trump's opponent do we really
believe that Donald Trump after all
these months decided suddenly
hire this guy because he damaged hillary
back in july
another implausible conjecture okay and
Krauthammer is exactly right of course
Senate Intelligence Committee Chairman
Richard Burr he says he doesn't
understand why this firing is happening
now even Senate Republicans are puzzled
by this we don't have that okay think he
said that so in other words oh there
there congressional Republicans who are
upset about this so theory number one
that this was basically a
straightforward firing of a guy who is
incompetent
it doesn't really wash ok theory number
two is the one the Democrats are pushing
there are a number two is the idea this
is an incompetent cover-up that
basically James Comey was getting this
close to uncovering the collusion
between the Trump campaign and the
Russians
okay that is theory number two that is
backed up by a piece today in the New
York Times that suggests that just days
before he was fired Comey asked for more
money in the Russia investigation this
is according to the New York Times they
say mr. Comey asked for the resources
during a meeting last week with rod
Rosen seeing the Deputy Attorney General
who wrote the goj memo that was used to
justify the firing of the FBI director
combing them briefs members of Congress
on the meeting in recent days okay
there's a bunch of Democrats who are
pushing this narrative that it was an
incompetent cover-up basically and
here's the Elizabeth Warren pushing that
narrative Comey was not fired because of
Hillary Comey was fired because of the
Russians okay so that is the idea that
the Democrats are pushing and again that
is backed up by a certain amount of
evidence number one Trump tweeting on
and ending the investigation as I
mentioned a moment ago the Russia Trump
collusion stories a total hoax when will
this taxpayer-funded charade end it's
also backed up to a certain extent by
the idea that Sean Spicer still doesn't
have that the administration still has
no real explanation for why exactly they
didn't fire Mike Flynn the the national
security adviser under Trump for 18 days
after they were informed that he was in
in basically in the pay of the Russians
at a certain point in time so all of
this was was not looking good for the
Trump administration then the Trump
administration makes it look even worse
by some of the worst PR I have ever seen
under any circumstances Kellyanne Conway
goes on TV and says the words you never
want to say if people are accusing you
of engaging in a cover-up she says this
I mean chairman bird has said it raises
serious concerns a Republican is head of
the Senate Intelligence Committee
investigation is concerned about the
timing of all
so the same senators that just voted to
confirm this man whose integrity is not
in doubt ninety four to six two short
weeks ago we're supposed to believe
I think the derogatory descriptions you
just made of him that's not fair and it
was Senator Schumer who said about mr.
bruised miss teen on the Senate floor
and April twenty ruins and I quote he
has a relative basis rate as he was
concerned is saying essentially this is
a cover-up today while he's wrong it's
not a cover-up in fact the president
makes very clear in his letter the fact
that mr. Comey on at least three
occasions assured the president that he
is not under investigation there when
you say that it's not a cover-up I just
fired the guy who was leading the
investigation again they're just it's
Nick Sounion it's Nick Sounion right I
mean flashback I want to say this to the
television audience I made my mistakes
but in all of my years of public life I
have never profited never profited from
public service I've earned every cent
and in all of my years of public life I
have never obstructed justice and I
think too that I could say that in my
years of public life that I welcome this
kind of examination because people have
got to know whether or not their
presidents a crook well I'm not a crook
whenever nobody says this is not a
cover-up I'm not a crook it never looks
good on TV and the Trump administration
is doing itself no favors through all of
this now do I buy this theory do I buy
this theory else wait a second why I
don't buy this theory but again I don't
know this is the biggest problem with
the Trump administration Trump wants
things done and no one says to him no
and then you cross out surrogates who
kiss his ass on national television
instead of giving good rationales for
him doing what he's doing so Sarah
Huckabee Sanders goes on national TV on
Tucker Carlson last night and what did
she say about the Trump Russia
investigation everybody is clamoring
this is a cover-up because of the Trump
Russia stuff what did she say as well
I've killed the Trump Russian
investigation my gosh Tucker when are
they going to let that go
it's been going on for nearly a year
frankly it's kind of getting absurd
there's nothing there
we've heard that time and time again we
heard it in the testimonies earlier this
week we've heard it for the last 11
months there is no there there it's time
to move on and it's frankly it's time to
focus on the things that the
American people care about it's time to
move on from the Trump Russia
investigation if you're trying to show
that you didn't fire economy to kill the
front brush investigation it is not
smart to send your surrogate on TV to
say that you want the trumpet Trump Rush
investigation to die and it's not smart
to tweet the day before you fire the guy
they want the Trump Russian
investigation to die it's just it's just
stupid okay like if you want Trump to
succeed he needs to not be stupid now
he's doing stupid things he's doing
stupid things right I mean this is a
stupid thing and it's allowing her left
to run wild over this entire thing that
Chris Matthews is going crazy over on
MSNBC saying it's a little with a
fascism Gavin the morning coming as a
showing data stop what we saw tonight is
the rule of law does not matter it's the
rule of political power you know we hear
President Trump say America first
tonight President Trump put himself
first I'm going to whiff of fascism
tonight I think it's fair to say so a
little wish a with a little whiff of I
don't care about the law on the boss
okay and this is the this is the line
the Democrats are going to take all the
way through Chuck Schumer taking this
line today also why did it happen
because it's a cover-up we need a
special investigator now now now this is
their routine now why did it happen
today we know the house is investigating
Russian interference in our elections
that benefited the Trump campaign were
these investigations getting too close
to home for the president it is
troubling that attorney general sessions
who had recused himself from the Russian
investigation played a role in firing
the man leading it okay so this is the
routine and Democrats are going to play
all the way down the line so you've got
theory number one and you make up your
mind on this there's theory number one
the Trump fired him for simple
incompetence and the timing was all
coinkidink okay then there's Theory
number two which is a Trump fired Comey
to stop the Trump Russia investigation
even though there's no evidence from the
Trump Russian investigation that
anything is going on and then there is
Theory number three and this is my
theory and you tell me if you think this
theory is correct or whether this theory
is incorrect but here is my theory as to
why Trump fired him but for that you're
gonna have to subscribe hahaha go over
to Daily wire calm right now for $8 a
month you can become a subscriber to the
daily wire.com or you can get your
annual subscription which will buy you
also a free copy of the Arroyo
a film set on our southern border about
a rancher attempting to defend his land
from the drug cartels great action
western by our own jeremy boring you can
get that right now and go over to daily
wire calm you can also watch the rest of
the show live be part of the mailbag
tomorrow and there are lots of other
goodies coming I promise
plus if you just want to listen later go
over to iTunes or SoundCloud you can
listen to us live I subscribe and leave
a review we always appreciate it we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
you